今別の話題でフジテレビが色々話題になって
中井君
あ、そうですね。それもで広告もテレビに出なくなったりとかであれについてどう思ってらっしゃいますか?
そんな大物か中井君ていうのはテレビの運命テレビを潰すほどの大物なのか?彼のスキャンダルが他のテレビ局は都合がええもんでそいつを利用してやっとんじゃないの?あんな自分とこだってあるよ。必ずどのテレビ局だってね。
[音楽]
表に出ないだけでああいうとこがいかんの
よ。あいつらの人の悪いところを利用する
。普段の報道から悪いとこばっかり探して
回ってそれを大げさんに言い立ててで
儲け取るやからね。1つのライバルが潰れ
てくれるんならありがたいもんによ。そこ
のスポンサーを自分のとこに入れりゃええ
。ちょっとあいつはあまりにも密もない
悪徳承人のやることよね。今のリメラルを
見取ると言いつけ外交昔韓国がやっとった
わな。アメリカに日本はこんなに悪いとこ
です。言って自分とか特しようとしとった
わな。あれとそっくりやないか。日本中に
フジテレビはこんなに悪い奴らですよ。
言ってとしとだから見るな見るな言るわけ
やね。見なけりゃスポンサーがつかない。
スポンサーつかなけりゃ会社マスコミ
の悪いとこが出たわな。他のマスコミや
けどね。フジテレビ自体についてはどう
思いますか?あんな昔からやっとるやない
か。
特にほら女優とか女の歌手なんてのは収代わりに使っとるんやからそれは良くて中井君に女をお世話したのが悪いないやろ。
[音楽]
フジテレビが悪いというよりかはたまたま最初にバレちゃって他のテレビ局がたくさん叩いてるっていう状態なんですかね。
マスコミがうちを叩いたのもそうやろ。あれ自分たちが悪いと知っとったからうちが出てくるのが困ったわけやろ。
リベラルは悪いんやからそいつがもう結果
が出ちまってどうしようどうしよう言っ
とるところにうちがハンリベラルで成果を
出したというあれは困るわね。そいつを
隠そうとしてうちを潰しまえばええという
のが盛りかけもそうやろ保守の教育超保守
やもんね。あそこだから潰しちまえという
ことやね。あれが大きなったら困る。それ
から言えばフジテレビはちょっと保守の方
やからね。他んとこがリベラルでみんな
潰したかったわね。リベラルの卑怯さ。
だから今度もトランプが勝っちまったわけやろ。リベラルがあんまり卑怯やもんでね。
校長は富士テレビに個人的な思いとかは特にないんですかね?
[音楽]
富士テレビはうちを曲と同じように扱っとったけどね。時々こう応援すると今度は反発が来るんや。視聴者と称するとからね消しから言ってそれで慌ててまたぶを批判するというそれ繰り返しとったわね。見とっても真のない連中やと思ったわね。
味方するならしっかり見方せえよと。反対
するなら最初から反対しとけよと思っとっ
たよね。そいつは例えば産経新聞にも現れ
とるやないか。産経はハンリベラルのはず
や。ところが反リベラルのは政治欄だけや
ないか。あれは社会面見ておらん。あれ
リベラルやん。前なんかの介合の時にね、
俺がちょっと話をしてリベラルが消しから
んていう話をした。フジテレビの人がうち
はリベラルじゃないからってそういうこと
を言ったんや。
そに対してない。あんた社会面リベラルやないか。あんたらリベラルとなんか保守とは何かが分かってないんじゃないの?分かってない。みんなに引っ張られとるわね。しっかりしやもう情けな。あ、男なら星というのは男が売り物のはずや。私は男じゃない。言っとるもんだ。
包丁と1
番確があるマスコミってどの媒体なんですか?
やっぱり朝日やろうね。
朝日新聞。うん。うん。うちをまずあれし
たのは毎日やけどね。3年毎日やったんや
けどあれは理由があった。3000毎日が
潰れかけとったもんだよね。なんかそう
いう刺激的なニュースを発掘したかったん
や。そこにうちが登場しちまった。それで
うちをこうとんでもない消しからん時代
錯誤のとこてわ騒いでおかげで潰れんやっ
たんや。後でまた潰れたけどな。それを見
てみんながうーっと乗ってきたい。うちも
売らんといかん。けど昔方のマスコミは
もうみんな潰れていっとるもんね。